الصراع في السودان الى منحا اخر وربما
ينتهي بتدخل خارجي لنصره احد جنرال النزاع
ما ينذر بحرب اهليه طويله الامد تقول
صحيفه الجارديان البريطانيه
الصحيفه نقلت عن الدبلوماسي الامريكي
ومبعوثها الخاص السابق الى القرن الافريقي
جافري
انه كلما طال امد الصراع سيسمح لجهات
خارجيه خبيثه بدعم جنرال على حساب اخر
رجل امريكا السابق للقرن الافريقي اكد على
ان الساحه متاحه امام القوات الخارجيه في
اشاره الى مجموعه فاغنر الروسيه ولذلك
يتوجب وقف الاقتتال في اسرع وقت ممكن
لتقويد التحرك الخارجي تحذيرات لم تاتي من
فراغ على ما يبدو بعد ان كشف القائد
السابق لفاينر مرات جابيدولا
موجوده في السودان منذ نهايه العام
مؤكدا ان هناك 200 عنصر من الوحده
الهجوميه الاولى داخل الاراضي السودانيه
حيث كانت مكلفه بتدريب قوات الدعم السريع
والشرطه المحليه
التحذيرات جاءت ايضا من الداخل على لسان
قائد جيش عبد الفتاح البرهان الذي كشف عن
وجود مرتزقه داخل السودان قدمت من دول
تشاد
وافريقيا الوسطى والنيجر
رئيس الوزراء السوداني السابق عبد الله
حمدوك حذر هو الاخر من امكانيه اندلاع حرب
اهليه في السودان ستشكل كابوسا قاطما على
البلاد والعالم
محاسن حداره العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات